what's happening
for much of the last century Finland
found itself at a Crossroads between
east and west
before becoming independent in 1917 the
Nordic nation was part of Sweden for
nearly seven centuries then a holding of
Imperial Russia and later a target of
the Soviet Union
with the motto swedes we are no more
Russians we cannot become therefore
Finns we must be Finland left its poor
agrarian economy behind to become a
stable free market economy driven by
services and Manufacturing and a member
of the European Union
with a border with Russia more than 1300
kilometers long maintaining neutrality
in the power struggle between East and
West was Central to the country's
survival
but the Ukraine war has pushed the
limits of that neutrality
I'm Tom McRae in Helsinki Finland had
previously refused to join NATO but
following Russia's invasion of Ukraine
Helsinki set aside its historical
neutrality and formally requested to
join the West's military Alliance but
Moscow has warned there could be
political or military consequences so it
was a Russian invasion possible and is
Finland prepared to face it the
president of Finland Salina Nesta talks
to Al Jazeera
president of Finland Soldier Nestor
thank you so much for talking to Al
Jazeera now Finland has uh I guess quite
proudly remains neutral for for many
decades so by joining NATO you are
giving some of that up how significant
was that decision
first of all we haven't called us
neutral rather
militarily unaligned
and the feeling we and Sweden have had
that from our own will
we remain as such and that
it even might stabilize the situation in
Baltic Sea
but
when President Putin announced that was
last December
that no enlargement of NATO anymore I
was immediately quite sure that we have
to do something you know we have been
enhanced partner in NATO we have a lot
of bilateral cooperation with the Sweden
with USA with UK all that already
but that was not enough anymore so
President Putin pushed Finland over the
edge to to join NATO let's say first he
pushed by his speech December speech us
to realize that we have to change we
have to go further and then the final
step was when he attacked
Ukraine then it was very clear a former
NATO Secretary General said that he
spent four years his entire term trying
to convince Finland to join NATO and
Putin managed to do it in four weeks can
you just explain I guess before uh the
war and before Putin's speech last year
what was the resistance uh in Finland to
joining NATO do you think I wouldn't
call it resistance actually we have had
in our governmental program for years
decades the statement that we keep
possibility of applying NATO membership
open and that has been a message in a
way so
even though our relation with Russia was
normal even good
we all the time kept in mind
developing our own Defense Forces in the
past Putin has said that if Finland does
join NATO you will be an enemy of Russia
so are you now an enemy of Russia now
that you have applied to join
well they have listed
countries which are not friendly and we
are on that list we would have been on
that list
even without applying the membership I
mean helping Ukraine like we do which we
would have done in every case
that already was enough to be listed
so that's the situation at the moment
but yes he has said that uh earlier on
four years ago
I mean butin has said that so far he
looks over the Porter and he sees uh
Finnish friend but if you join his his
enemy so
and how does that that's his position
yes and but how does that sit with with
you that you are now an enemy to Russia
well
that's what he has said so we know
and you know where you stand now
actually
I decided just before we made the
decision to call him and tell him that
well we are turning Donato
he took it very calmly in the spring
but uh
like I tried to tell you
we have had our our experiences from
centuries
not that friendly one is always with
Russia so that has been not forgotten we
are all the time prepared Finland uh has
one of the strongest militaries uh in
the world widely regarded proportional
yes of course yeah having having
um you know especially when it comes to
Winter Warfare yeah so did you not think
that that might be enough a deterrence
to stop Russia potentially uh invading
and you could have relied on your
military power and might and your I
guess insight into how Russians might
have been looking to invade if they were
indeed do you think that you could have
fallen back on that would that have been
enough instead of taking that I guess
greater leap and joining NATO and
getting their protection okay let's go
back to 90s first
we have been building up our defense in
spite of the fact that in the end of
1990s
well it was seen that cold war is over
and friendship will
remain we have all all the time peeled
up our
own Defense Forces but understanding
that that is not enough that's why I
have been all the time advocating that
European Union should do more together
for security and that we became an
enhanced partner in NATO
uh we
have direct
agreements with Sweden with the UK with
the USA
bilaterally and even trilateral
agreements so it was kind of a company
combination our own forces and
capabilities plus working close together
with EU NATO neighbors even
transatlantically
so I I think that was considered to be
enough
before all this and I want to add that I
have said earlier on many years ago that
my belief is that
if there would be a war time which was
very theoretical which I said always
so those who have similar interests
will fight together
even if there are no applications of
memberships that's what has happened in
every Great War I mean world wars you
just have allies if you have same
interest so maybe this combination was
something we relied on
before Russia
gave its opinion and attacked so Ukraine
so seeing how The Invasion has played
out and I guess a lot of the West not
sending troops into Ukraine did that
play a part in wanting to join NATO
because uh you know they've been crying
out for uh air defense from the U.S and
from the EU
um was that a consideration that was
given that you saw what had happened in
Ukraine and realized that that these
countries were not willing to mobilize
troops into Ukraine to help defend their
land I I think that
we were well aware even before these
these attacks that nato in itself
doesn't kill the fiber article cover to
countries with certain are not members
but what I explained to you also
different situation
if the world is in fire everybody is
involved so it's quite quite natural
that those who have similar interests in
a way cooperate
was there any pressure from other
countries to join NATO for you and
Sweden to join NATO because it might
have if you didn't it might have seemed
like you were I guess standing back
standing aside and in a way I guess
supporting or not condemning uh Russia
and their invasion of Ukraine
uh first of all
we very well know knew and it was said
by many countries that you are welcome
to Nato
but no one really tried to push us
because
I think people wanted to avoid shots
of behavior
what surely Ukrainian situation showed
that in shorts cases NATO doesn't cover
so that was our reaction
it seems like the decision to join NATO
uh has happened because of the war much
quicker than it probably would have at
any other time only only a few months so
uh how has the public reacted to that if
you look uh opinion polls from January
you see
clear rise all the day after day so we
ended up from 25 to to approximately 18.
that was very natural actually I guess
opinion polls are one thing but you know
go taking it to a referendum uh is
another was there any consideration of
ever of ever doing that I had earlier on
an opinion that we should have a very
reliable
uh understanding what people think and
the most reliable you surely get through
referendum but now that the figures pull
off the poll done by different
institutions gave the same results I I
think it's proven that since what Finn's
thought putting the war to one side and
hopefully it won't be going on for too
much longer
what are the longer term implications of
of joining nato in the in the decades
ahead do you think
in the future yes
well I think that
we have done
actually finished in a way our our
institutional
organizational security but that doesn't
end up the I'm sure that in Finland we
will
take care of our own defense too because
we do understand that we have half of
the NATO Russian border
uh as our duty to keep it clean now just
on uh NATO membership and where it is at
at the moment 28 of the 30 countries
have already already ratified your
membership Hungary has said it's going
to do so in December turkey is still
holding out so how confident are you
that you will become a member and when
do you think that that might be at the
end I'm quite confident but giving a
timetable that is quite difficult how I
see
the situation
its president everyone's the solution is
only in president erdogan's head
actually and we have several times said
that we condemn all the terrorism uh
also that one which they face but
We are following and that was actually
agreed with turkey we are following the
European convention on deporting
deportations and we will follow NATO if
NATO develops some mechanisms against
terrorism these are the two actually
obligations we have and we have followed
them so what do you think is the
sticking point or what is holding turkey
back from ratifying you I think I think
that it is commonly known that turkey
has been
unsatisfied not only with what Sweden or
less Finland
is doing but also with other countries
and I I think they want to raise the
question now on discussion and on
knowledge
so
it's very difficult to make any
estimations when
when they will and president everyone
will react but I'm confident and
I'm not worried because 28 countries
have now said that yes you're capable of
joining NATO and that we see that you're
worthy of getting the Article 5 coverage
that 28 countries has already said it
what's do you have a message to
president erdogan
you know the the delay a lot of critics
and analysts have said that he might be
delaying um to play to a domestic
audience ahead of the elections next
year do you think that's the case and
and if it is is that just playing
politics with something that has got
much larger ramifications
uh it might very well be we got an
opinion poll in from turkey and
it seems that a slight majority of
people would like turkey to accept our
ratify our membership but in
erdogan's party
the resistance is
maturity so
that gives a hint of the domestic
policies like I said
we should not be very worried but surely
expecting that ratification will take
place your prime minister has said
warned of the risks of turkey and
Hungary delaying what do you think those
risks are I do repeat what I said
earlier on
on February March that
even though we were not expecting any
military actions reactions from Russia
the might
well take place nasty things and
uh that's a game day no to how to play
like what
what uh hybrid World includes almost
every possibility you can imagine
one of the ways that uh finland's
looking to defend itself is is build a
fence I believe the main political
parties have back plans to to build a
fence which will be equipped with
surveillance cameras sensors and topped
with razor wire to stop Russians from
seeking asylum in Finland
do you not think though that building a
wall
um would is a very uneuropean solution
to the problem well we have seen some
walls in
in Baltic countries in Poland in Greece
I would not actually call it as a wall
it's a fence and well we can't fence all
the
1 300 kilometers so how I have
understood that our
photo cards
think that
Finns to certain extent nearby to
official
border crossing places
the possibility of keeping an order
and I would call it more a fence of
arranging to arrange order
own border then so as not to deter
people from trying to find asylum in
Finland well to order them through a
process rather than to block order them
to process yes that's in my opinion the
the idea of fence and we all know what
are the international
agreements if people asking for Asylum
you have to study the case it's
obviously a significant concern of um
you know as we saw recently with the
Russian mobilization and yes hundreds of
thousands of Russians fleeing the
country in all directions
yeah yeah exactly so how concerning how
many people could you expect or are you
expecting to potentially you know try
and try and enter Finland from Russia
actually we had an experience in 2015
winter time when suddenly
people
started to come from Russia asking for
Asylum and at the end we found out that
people from
32 nationalities came through
asking for her son
I do not believe that the same would now
be repeated we haven't seen any sign of
that not at least yet but
uh well Warfare
in Ukraine Warfare elsewhere maybe even
the impact of climate change might push
people
moving and it is possible that they move
also via Russia
I just want to quickly talk about your
relationship with Putin because I've
you've spoken to him probably more than
most world leaders
um
were you surprised that he went ahead
with the invasion to begin with and what
do you think that initially he was
trying to achieve
yes I was surprised
what we have seen eight years almost
nine years now that they hold certain
areas in dombas and Crimea
but
a sudden attack to clearly invade the
whole country or change the regime of of
Ukraine that was really surprising uh
surprising in a way that well we surely
heard from
late last year that it might be possible
but it was surprising to see that how
widely the the preparations were done
and the final attack yeah were you
surprised now though uh seven or eight
months on into the war at I guess the
lack of success that Russia has had many
people thought that they would be able
to take Ukraine in a matter of weeks
yeah
um and and occupy it that clearly hasn't
happened so where do you think the war
is at now
um well that happened did not happen
also because suddenly Europe and the
West United very much had gave and are
still giving a lot of help to Ukraine
it's a
almost impossible now to estimate
what happens at the end when the peace
will reveal and
yeah
when you look and listen to Buddhist
speeches
yeah I have said that in poker terms he
has put all in including himself at his
fate and
that makes it well even more dangerous
in a way that I do not believe that he
is going to give up
so what do you think that actually means
though that he's not going to give up
well
maybe he will do anything maybe he will
go to any any length including maybe
still thinks that he can win no I
wouldn't speculate that much with the
nuclear Armament no but
but if he is all in and like you say he
himself has put his reputation uh you
know clearly on the line here and he's
been backed into a corner you think that
his only way out is to fight fight out
rather than take a backward Step At
least it means that
that
like I said it's impossible to see when
the war would end
well if Ukraine wins that would end it
but
it's a long journey till is there a way
for Europe for the UK for the us to try
and de-escalate at this point where do
you think the next step is in this war
going into what is going to No Doubt be
a long cold winter how do you see the
next few months playing out yes about
escalation what we have seen actually
the fears concerning escalation where
you know we're higher up in February
March and little by little I would say
that that well stronger Armament has
been given to Ukraine all that kind of
things
and what happens
during the winter
it's a measurement of resilience
not only ukrainians but Europeans
and on the other hand also in Russia
we we have seen more
people
in Russia reacting or at least being
unsatisfied with the situation and even
their living standards have
are it's much more difficult at the
moment so
it's a competition of resilience in a
way what we are facing a president of
Finland Saudi so thank you for talking
to Al Jazeera thank you it has been a
great pleasure thank you very much
[Music]